I'd
like to believe that critical thinking
is woven into pretty much everything we
do here on the Rubin report,
but today's show is going to have an
even keener focus on this all
encompassing topic.
At the end of the day,
whether we're talking about politics,
religion,
or current events,
it all boils down to critical thinking,
the definition of which is quote,
the objective analysis and evaluation of
an issue in order to form a judgment end
quote,
can we really look at the world the way
it truly is,
not the way we want it to be.
Can we set aside our faith based hopes
to analyze real world problems or his
faith actually a part of the problem as
opposed to being the solution each week
I try to have conversations that exist
in this space without resorting to ad
hominem attacks and Straw man arguments.
That guiding principle is fully based in
critical thinking and moral reasoning.
Joining me this week is Peter
Boghossian,
philosophy instructor,
critical thinker and author of a manual
for creating atheists.
Peter's book is a really incisive,
clear take on why critical thinking is
important,
how faith based thinking can be
dangerous,
and also relates what you can do to
spread ideas based on fact and reason
with your friends and family.
He writes in an understandable and
relatable style on topics that many are
afraid to touch on,
even with the people closest to them.
He gives the reader the very tools to
help people trapped by faith based
thinking.
Yes,
I did say help.
Their help is exactly what I believe is
needed in this situation.
When your beliefs aren't based in reason
and critical thinking,
it creates a space where extremism can
creep in.
This of course,
isn't beholden to one religion or
ideology.
Anytime you throw reason in fact out the
window to trade it with ideas that
aren't provable,
you create the very breeding ground that
extremism needs to spread.
It's not a coincidence that in places
where gays,
women and minorities are treated poorly
are also the places where religion has
often been a substitute for clear moral
thinking.
By the way,
uh,
we here in the West could do a much
better job of this ourselves.
I know we're more focused on Islamic
extremism on this show,
but there are all kinds of extremism in
the world.
You can't deal with any of these
ideologies with half truths and by
shooting the messengers,
you must deal with them by looking at
them head on and tackling the ideologies
with better ideas and moral clarity.
We live in a time when religious
extremism is on the rise.
I'm going to guess that we probably
don't have many religious extremists
watching this show,
so I don't know how much of an effect I
can have on those people.
The people that I can have an effect on,
however,
is you guys people out there from every
walk of life,
from all over the globe who want to do
the work of finding out what brings us
together,
not what tears us apart.
I firmly believe that critical thinking
is the solution.
Critical thinking doesn't care about
your race,
your sexuality or your nationality is a
roadmap to solving serious issues and
combating superstitious thinking.
That has led to many real world
problems.
Much of the right in America is led by
Christian religious ideology.
Much of the left,
while not guided by religion,
has become as dogmatic in its beliefs
between the two is where most clear
minded free thinking people live.
It's what my guest on next week show Ali
Rizvi he refers to as the new center.
I think by letting go of our
superstitions and focusing on real
solutions,
we can change the world for the better.
Either that or we can leave it up to the
zealots after all the world is what you
make of it.
Peter goes in as a philosophy
instructor,
critical thinker and author of a manual
for creating atheists.
He's also an anterior aggressive warrior
and can back it up with some Jujitsu.
Peter,
welcome to the show.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
Really looking forward to our chat.
I am looking forward to it as well.
You know,
every week I feel like I'm connecting
with people that I know in the digital
space and mostly through 140 characters
and I put you in that group.
You just did three hours with Rogan.
I did.
We had an interesting conversation.
How you feeling?
You came up,
you came up to good.
I feel great.
Did he say good things about me?
We said nothing.
Well,
you know,
that's the thing.
We don't.
I think part of it is when people are
together and they're sincere,
I think they'll,
they'll either agree or disagree or
there'll be a convergence around those
ideas.
And I started off when we were talking,
thinking that I feel like I know you,
like I feel that the stuff that you
think about and the values that you have
are in congruence with my own values.
And I think part of that comes from,
from the uh,
type of honesty with oneself.
Yeah.
Well we're obviously going to talk a lot
about those values and I think it really
is cool that this,
this group of people come together.
You were sort of in this a little bit
before me and connected with Sam and
some of those other guys,
but now Rogan,
Christina Hoff,
sommers,
all these people who don't necessarily
agree on everything.
Don't come from the same walks of life
or the same socioeconomic separate,
whatever,
that we've all sort of come together
because we have these base principles,
apps that we want to put out there.
Yeah,
I think that's right.
And I think that it's so.
So here's one way to think about it.
We often think about the right and the
left on some kind of align.
So there's the far right,
which is obviously on the far right of
the line,
the far left and the middle.
There's this philosophy,
there's a French philosopher has this
idea of a horseshoe theory.
You take the ends of the line and you
bend them together.
The far left and the far right are
closer to each other than they are to
the center.
Yeah.
And so I think that that's a helpful
heuristic or helpful way to look at some
of these issues.
And for me it was,
you know,
rather than give a geological account
about how this came to be for,
for me,
what's always interesting is when
I look at the mean spiritedness,
the anger,
the tactics of the regressives,
they're just so fundamentally contrary
to what my values are and for the sort
of person that I want to become.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and I do see that that horseshoe,
that far left in that far right and the
left the regressive seem extraordinarily
angry and eager to smear those people
with racist,
sexist,
homophobic,
etc.
If you don't buy into certain,
even if you ask questions as opposed to
buying into something they have made any
kind of discourse almost impossible.
Yeah.
Well,
we've talked a lIttle bit about that and
i.
Sam said something,
sam harris said something about how it's
almost like scorched earth.
I think I'm loosely quoting what he said
because the tactics have been so bad.
But before we get into all that,
let's talk about you a little bit so
people can understand where you come
from.
All this and,
and the book that you've written,
which I just read this week and manual
for creating atheists.
It was,
it was wonderful.
it was what I tried to do here actually,
uh,
which I guess goes to what you said at
the top because it was understandable
you were trying to give people the tools
to go about talking about,
you know,
reasoning and,
and morality without taking the leap of
faith.
Yeah.
And,
and asking people starts off in.
So thank you for the,
for the book.
You enjoyed the book.
I fully did.
It really did.
And if you didn't,
you tell me.
I absolutely.
Okay.
So that's the type of sincerity and I'd
appreciate that.
So,
so the book talks about in the
forthcoming app atheist,
which talks about how to have more civil
productive conversations with people to
help them break through dogmatism,
to help them break through these deep
seated beliefs that they hold and that
they think that they're better people
because they hold these beliefs.
So how to really have productive
conversations and engage people.
Yeah.
So I think the best way to jump off on
this is let's just define some terms and
I've done this in one incarnation or
another a few times on the show and
we've talked about religion and atheism
and agnosticism and all that.
But why don't you just give me some
basic definitions,
which is sort of how you start the book.
So just what is an eighth?
Yes.
So the way I define ads,
I think it's right.
These are placeholder terms.
I'm willing to revise those.
I don't have an atheist is a person who
doesn't have sufficient evidence to
warrant belief in god,
but if they were given that evidence
then they would believe so inherent in
the term atheist or the way that I use
it is a sort of open mindedness.
Right.
Which is funny to me,
and that's the way you describe it in
the book because there seems to be a
certain subset of people that think that
atheists are actually the most closed
minded people,
but that's not the way you are defining.
And maybe that's just sort of the
personalities that have been publicly
attached to them.
To a certain extent.
We,
we can understand why someone would
think that because the word theist is
contained with the word atheist and just
as theorists tend to have these dogmas
where they latch onto religious
propositions,
faith,
faith promises to faith.
So two,
one would think that atheists does.
But again,
I think that the faithful have
constructed these narratives to,
to make it as if there's some kind of a
parallelism,
assymetry of belief.
Look,
we believe these things.
You guys believe that we,
we,
we have beliefs that are predicated on
no evidence just like you do.
Right?
And I,
I don't,
I,
I think that's a type of insincerity.
I don't think that people who are honest
with themselves and have a minimal
level,
you know,
basically enough intelligence to tie a
shoe,
a shoe is,
I don't think that it's possible to come
to that conclusion.
Yeah.
So,
so before we go too deep on that,
what are the other,
what are the other terms we should just
define right at the beginning?
So agnosticism for example,
um,
I would,
you don't,
you're not big on.
No,
I don't like that.
I don't like the term.
I think it's a,
it's a useless tournament we need to do
away with it.
You don't believe in santa claus?
No.
So you were a santa claus,
a atheist or don't understand to close.
Agnostic,
right.
So the word agnostic is gives wiggle
room worse.
No wiggle room should exist.
The default to any belief shouldn't be.
Maybe the default should probably be no,
unless I have sufficient evidence to
believe.
But again that's part of the hijacking
of the narrative.
Right.
So that's interesting.
So a lot of people I've heard lately,
they described themselves as agnostic
atheist.
That seems to be like the new or have
you heard about that one where it gives
them,
I guess a little more wiggle room,
but you're saying that that in a way
that sort of cheating the,
the idea here,
right?
Yeah.
And maybe people self described that way
because they feel they want to reap some
social benefits from it.
Maybe they feel that they don't want to
offend people or insult people or make
people feel bad so that they use these
wiggle terms.
Yeah.
So in the book.
Well,
first off,
is there anything else we should define?
Just real quick.
All right.
I don't know.
I don't think so,
but if,
um,
if we've defined something and it's,
you're right,
it's important to define words and those
can be placeholders for later on because
if someone says,
I'm an agnostic atheist,
I'll say,
well what do you mean by that?
And I can challenge or what have you,
but if not it's like two ships passing
each other.
Not like we don't know what the
conversation is about.
And there was a lot of that in the book
where you're talking about,
you know,
people with faith and people without
faith or a nonbeliever verse believer,
whatever,
however you want to define it there
they're talking about two different
things and that sometimes makes the
conversation really kinda crazy.
It does.
And that's the problem with faith is
that it has a broad semantic range and
people try to use the term to do some
work that it doesn't do,
like they try to use the term to protect
like,
well I believe that muhammad fluid
having a winged horse or I believe jesus
walked on water fasting or the dalai
lama incarnates through bodies where it.
But I,
you just say you have faith,
your wife loves you or you have faith in
a plant.
So they use that term as an umbrella
term to almost cover their beliefs from
any make an impervious to reason.
And I just don't think that's,
that's a very sincere way to approach
any inquiry.
Right?
So I think a lot of people just from
this first five or six minutes are going
to say,
well,
this guy,
this guy is a pretty open minded atheist
like that.
That's going to be part of it.
And I think one of the things you said
right at the beginning of the book is
you don't really define yourself as an
atheist.
And I thought you were.
I thought your reasoning was actually
really clever.
Can you go into that?
What you tell me what you got it and
then I'll,
I'll.
Well basically you were saying I don't
define myself as someone that doesn't
believe in leprechaun.
Right.
So,
but,
but yet there seems to be with atheists,
there seems to be so much onus on them
to constantly have to talk about it or,
or whatever it is.
I've only been in this kind of.
I never even publicly said that I was an
atheist.
Yeah.
Literally it was about two months ago,
I think when milo yiannopoulos was on
the show,
I always considered myself sort of a
friend of the atheist community.
I always liked atheists.
I like free thinkers.
I like critical thinkers.
It never,
it wasn't something that really hit me
one way or another.
I didn't feel like I needed to say,
all right,
I have to make this announcement or this
announcement.
but somehow in that conversation with
him,
I had finally got to my breaking point
or something.
Well that was good then.
It was a good car.
So Yeah,
it was all good
honesty though.
Public asta.
And so I think that the Word atheist
still has some negative connotations and
a lot of negativity is attached to it,
but I don't.
I think that atheism is a conclusion and
it's ultimately,
it's much less important that then
epistomological hygiene if you were like
thinking about how you come to knowledge
and making sure that,
that,
that those ways to come to knowledge or
reliable.
Because that's the other thing that was
a big realization for me a long time ago
is that that faith,
faith claims are knowledge claims.
So when someone makes a faith claim,
they're making a claim about the world.
Like I have faith because of x.
So people use faith as a process to get
to a claim about the world.
I mean the whole thing is just so
bizarre twisted,
but unfortunately where we live or it's
surrounded surrounding us,
but I don't,
I don't have.
It's really weird to me.
Like I'll go to,
I'll speak an atheist conference and
people would be singing about being an
atheist since I just,
I can't.
It's just unfathomable.
Right.
Well that's why your description of it
felt decent to me.
You know what I mean?
It does.
It certainly,
as I said,
I didn't talk about it until three
months ago.
It's never.
I don't think it will ever be something
that defines me.
What defines me are my thoughts and my,
the breadth of all the things that I am,
but that's just to define yourself by
saying you don't believe in.
Actually it doeSn't make that much
sense.
Right?
Yeah,
and
I'm trying to think about defining
yourself in terms of your thought.
I don't even know if I had to do that.
I mean,
I think it important to ask yourself,
what kind of person do you want to be
like,
you know,
I want to be a kind person.
I want to be a compassionate person.
I am very confident that those values
are derived through reason and that we
can articulate ways to get through those
very clearly,
but I'm not.
I'm not Sure if he hit me.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe I want to be tHe type of person
who's willing to revise my beliefs.
Maybe I want to be the type of person
who's inquisitive and trustful of reason
and who treats people well,
you know,
maybe that's the kind of person I want
to become.
so maybe those things are identify self
identify with those,
but I don't.
It's just an odd thing to me to latch
that onto an identity.
Yeah.
Well I,
I certainly agree with that.
So a lot of what you're doing in the
book is really,
I think you actually use this word is to
deprogram people from faith and I
thought using that word was particularly
interesting because you're viewing it as
sort of,
you know,
we all enter this,
this life sort of as a clean slate and
then we're programmed with this stuff
and you're trying to give everyone the
tools to,
to deprogram.
Yeah,
that's exactly right.
We have been indoctrinated by ideas,
culture.
We have.
Everybody has a kind of cultural myopia
that's reinforced by religion and
beliefs.
So how do we help people to become more
reflective about their beliefs?
How do we help people to become less
dogmatic about what they,
about their thoughts and,
and you know,
maybe maybe that's why like for me even
the is and part of an identity,
but maybe that's because it's a dominant
heteronormative or you know,
so I mean,
I,
I don't,
I don't know.
What I do know is that people think that
havIng certain beliefs makes them a
better person.
Dan debt talks about this in terms of
belief and belief and part of the
problem is once you start taking that,
you're holding beliefs makes you a
better person.
You're much less likely to revise those
because it moves from the realm of
epistemology that is knowledge to the
realm of morals and you don't want to be
that guy like you don't want to be.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I'm with you.
The difference between knowledge and
morals,
which people seem to conflate
constantly,
right?
Yeah.
And it's interesting in terms of the,
the regressive left and the,
the idea of race.
When people talk about race that is just
so charged and so politicized that they
have made it almost impossible for a
sincere inquirer to ask a question
without being smeared or labeled in some
way,
and we've lost the ability,
we've lost the ability in an academic
context to ask sincere questions that we
get.
The only way to solve any problem,
the first step is to be honest about it.
If you're not honest about it,
you're not going to solve it.
And you've written about this.
And Douglas Murray was on sam's
podcasts.
Other people have spoken buts.
I've tweeted about this.
I wrote about this.
If you do not allow questions than
extremists are eager to come in with
answers.
And so that's one of the consequences
that we see and we see this in a
religious landscape.
Very it,
especially with islam.
Now with me,
we see this terrible problem.
So we're,
we're jumping ahead a little bit.
I'm gonna.
Follow you on this jump.
Um,
so when it relates to,
to the left,
now I assume you're basically someone
that comes from the left,
right?
I mean,
from everything I knew,
classical liberal,
liberal class every,
every virtually every sense.
Yeah.
So I assume that also that you feel the
same way I do that it's your job to
police them more than the.
Right.
Like for me,
people always say to me,
well,
why aren't you attacking the right as
much?
And it's like I see I have not part of
the right.
I do attack them.
I,
I don't think I've ever voted for a
republican in my life.
Not,
I'm not a fan of the democrats and I'm
not a democrat.
I'm an independent,
but I.
But for me to police the people that I'm
not part of,
you know,
it,
it just seems silly.
I want to police my guys.
Do you feel that?
I mean,
is that part of what you do and
I feel to me it's more germane in the
sense that the left,
the regressives have taken over
academia.
They have literally hijacked the
institutions and now they're
institutionalizing these policies which
are really rather extreme by any in any,
any classical liberal would be horrified
at what their speech codes,
microaggressions.
Troy,
it's horrifying and they're Basically
robbing a generation of people have the
possibility of being able to think
clearly and critically and their ever
increasing the threshold.
People's threshold for what they
consider to be offensive or the types of
conversations they'll have is
continuously dropping.
So for me it's personal only and then I
have to deal with this every single day
and I write.
I mean it's,
it's the most personal thing.
Yeah,
it's,
it's endemic now.
Why?
Why don't you criticize the rightest
much?
Well,
I mean,
look,
I have criticized the right,
you've criticized the right.
Think about the type of criticism you
have to label against a guy who is a
bonafide.
Can I start?
We're on.
Your shows were away.
Yeah,
everyone always asked me before they
swear I probably,
I probably asked me for a while.
That's fine.
Yeah.
I mean think of,
think about about,
you know,
like huckabee,
who is a bonafide fucking lunatic,
right?
I mean think about guys like Donald
Trump.
I mean these guys are so outside,
not even actually that's status.
They're not outside the mainstream or at
least have that place.
Yeah.
And labeling a sort of criticism against
that type of crazy is very different
from people for whom I feel sympathies
for these impulses they have.
They have very decent impulses that base
and we need to be careful that because
they're so insincere and dishonest that
we don't disregard their whole message.
Like the onus falls upon us to think
clearly about that,
into really,
okay privilege,
I got it,
you know,
this gender thing,
but to really take a step back and
separate the message from the messenger
so that we don't discount the whole
thing.
Yeah.
I'm
very,
very aware of that all the time,
you know,
because I know that I'm attacking the
trigger warnings and safe space and all
that stuff and I don't want to throw the
baby out with the bathwater and I know
that there are legitimate racial issues
in early legitimate socioeconomic issues
and all of that stuff.
But because of the way these guys have
behaved and frame the debate,
they've made it extremely difficult to
separate legitimate issues.
That's exactly right.
From pure craziness.
So I think what's interesting related to
someone like you that comes from a place
where you're writing and talking about
moral clarity and and critical thinking,
this has to be.
It's almost like doubly worse for you in
a way to be part of this because there's
the,
there's the thinking part,
the spiritual part.
Like it's just a lot mixed into one
crazy thing.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
I mean everybody,
you had I think nicola here and other
people have given geological accounts of
how we got into the situation,
but I think the thing that people really
aren't thinking about or talking about
that much or what are the implications
for these things.
I mean,
what are the philosophical.
What does this mean?
What did this would interest.
We're both speaking quickly.
We have so much to sacrifice,
so much to get up and go,
what does this mean when we've created
academic environments in which people in
which professors are terrified to give a
dissenting opinion and then when
dissenting.
I mean something from,
from the regressive party line.
What does that mean
for a second,
let's define dissenting because it's
barely dissenting.
It's literally just saying anything
other descending.
It's not like you're saying something
that's really against what the
mainstream belief is.
It's pretty much anything like,
you know,
be okay with someone else wearing a
halloween costume that you may not like.
ThAt's the tour sort of dissenting.
Right?
And that's the kind of craziness that
you get when you.
So it's again,
it's the issue of how we got there is
extremely interesting and valuable.
I'm,
I'm interested in recently my work has
been focusing on what does that mean for
one's intellectual life?
Like what does that mean for one's
ability to reflect on issues?
What does that mean for one's ability to
make decisions about things that really
matter?
Not halloween costumes.
I understand that some people think that
matters,
but that's just evidence of an inability
to show moral triage,
you know,
to prior to indexically partners prior
to some kind of a hierarchy to identify
that one need and another need and show
why that's important.
And the way that you do that is through
reason and rationality.
That's how you get there and the way
that you.
So when you attack safe spaces and when
you attract trick,
true warnings,
you're actually,
this is the key thing,
you're actually doing them a favor
because,
because you're giving them an
opportunity,
you're giving people an opportunity if
their values are true,
like if their values are morally
correct.
And I do believe that there's such a
thing as being morally correct and
obviously they do as well or they
couldn't be espousing.
And that's just parenthetically,
that's the interesting difference
between,
that's the,
uh,
the contradiction in their beliefs
between being lost.
My train of thought.
Well that I think,
I think you're going that they think
that,
oh yeah.
So right.
Yeah.
So,
so you.
So these people,
they have the legacy of relativism,
but yet the values that they put forth a
radical egalitarianism,
you cannot be a relativist entity.
Galitary and safe.
You cannot say everything is relative
and then all systems are equal.
So one of the things that you're doing,
you're doing,
they'll look at it as to them,
but I will look at it as to advance
their cause.
One of the things you're doing is you're
giving people an opportunity to reflect
on how they know what they know,
and the only way you can do that is
through an unsafe space.
The only way you can do that Is to
really take a look at these ideas and
examined these ideas.
There just is no other way.
So if they have their values are
arbitrary and subject to cultural
capriciousness,
unless they can be rationally derived
and they've taken out the engine of
rationality once they've created spaces
in which you can ask these questions.
Yeah,
so that's why I've a few times I'll say
that the road to hell is paved with good
intentions that I believed that these
guys.
Actually.
Joe rogan fought me on this when I said
this,
I said,
I believe these guys,
like with the athletic thing on real
time with sam harris and all that I did,
while his intentions were good.
You know what I mean?
He was intending to try to protect the
other joe.
Basically it was like,
nah,
he's a hollywood guy.
He's just protecting her zone,
his own internals and actor.
He's an actor.
That's it and he's,
he's out for number one fund,
but I guess that's probably what really
is perverse about what's going on on the
left because by taking kids,
by taking college kids whose thoughts
aren't fully formulated yet and then
putting this thing on them,
they think they're doing everything for
good intentions,
but then they're going to walk out into
the world realizing the world doesn't
really react that way.
Yeah,
and if they're listening to this and
they're just dumping on you and hate you
and hate in me,
I think it's perhaps a nice,
helpful heuristic to think about it in
terms of standing for the flag.
An example on the rIght,
people on the right are big on respect
for the flag.
They've made their own thing sacred,
but I don't think that's important.
I think what's important is to teach
people why they should stand for the
flag,
what our values mean and and that's why
they're standing.
It's not an icon,
but I think that the same property holds
on the left.
They have to.
They have to start being honest and
realizing that if their values really
are true,
then they have to subject those values
to scrutiny and then we have to create
spaces.
we have to create environments where the
marketplace of ideas,
we can have a discourse and a dialectic
above these things.
Exactly.
If that's just a little different,
we just do the do the officers.
That's why they should be thankIng you.
I'm,
I mean,
I'm being facetious.
I'm being really sincere.
That's why they should be thanking you
because if not then that means their
values are arbitrary.
So when I talked about this with milo
and the and the college thing,
you know,
he said that what this really is about,
this isn't about left and right.
He was saying that thIs really is about
authoritarians versus the word of
porsche and that's what you're really
talking.
That's the horseshoe.
Yeah.
So,
so somehow though,
I think this is related to religion to
right,
we can relate this very much to
absolutely.
Thinking of religion.
So can you go down that path for me a
little bit?
yeah.
So the,
they use many of the same mechanisms.
They have things that are sacred.
In this case,
it's the rise of the victim,
the victim hood culture.
They have certain questions,
certain ideas can't be questions,
can't be challenged to churches or safe
space to university campuses are safe
space.
And,
and so here's what's super interesting.
When I did a talk a few years ago,
uh,
I dunno,
five years,
I don't even know it's on youtube.
Jesus,
the easter bunny.
And other delusions just say no.
Yeah,
I know if you saw that or not,
doesn't matter.
But,
but the people who protested that were
not chrIstians,
I had some christians come in,
the audience,
I speak all around the world.
People are in general with very few
exceptions.
Christians and muslims are very civil to
christians.
I go out for beer off afterwards,
but it's the regressive leftist who,
I mean this,
I mean really think about this.
This is,
this is like the feminist is rice said
to joe today.
It's like the feminists in bed with the
islamists,
I mean is you just could not conceive of
a relationship that was more eight to
thetical t two,
one,
one of those parties interests,
right?
So,
so it's interesting that,
that,
and I'm pretty sure that the,
the islamic,
no,
uh,
that they're never going to treat these
women any better.
Right?
It's.
So what is that?
What is that?
I'm sorry to cut you off,
but what is that?
That,
what are they doing?
So they just view.
So these feminists for whatever,
they just view the other as more
oppressive than they are,
so they just have to give them their
credit.
I mean,
is that,
it's really that simple and that is a
comp.
I have thought about that a long time.
I think it deals with the color of
people's skin oppression.
I think it deals with,
you know,
this whole third wave feminism that I
still don't understand.
Uh,
I,
I don't know,
I don't,
I cannot explain to you,
and I've thought about it extensively,
how this cohabitation fine,
not a marriage,
but how,
how this,
how this bizarre relationship came to
be.
I still cannot understand it.
and the most recent event at goldsmiths
dot dawkins was tweeting on and such.
I mean that is,
that should be a case study for people.
The,
that is even boggling my mind to even
think about trying to understand that.
Right?
And then so that and,
and all of this and all the stuff that
we're talking about in this discussion,
it shows again why that if you don't
help the reformers,
the actual reformers who are trying to
change make things better for women and
gays and might not even question if you
don't help these people and you keep
framing these people as the problem.
Well what do you,
do?
You get the rise of trump?
Yeah.
I'm just going to say that extreme.
I think my treat was something like a,
if you have create environments in which
you can ask questions,
extremist step in with solutions.
And I think that that's exactly right.
Could this,
so really could,
do you think that this atmosphere that,
that trump has taken advantage of their,
their sense of palpable fear,
right in America that I haven't felt
before.
I really do.
I sense that people are feeling like
everything is screwed up,
that there's,
we have this terrorism stuff.
We don't know what the answers are.
There's this refugee thing.
We're all children of refugees are
descendants of refugees here,
unless you came over as a slave or a
american indian,
right?
If you were actually indigenous to this
land.
Um,
and I just had this sense that people
don't know what's going on.
and then when you shut down the people
on the left,
zach,
then of course trump.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I really wish that every single
person listening to that would put the
rewind button and listen to that again.
So if you're one of these people who
thinks that you're doing the world a
favor by creating,
you know,
triggering,
protecting people who are,
you know,
you want to protect the sensitivities of
others.
Again,
not a bad impulse at all,
but the consequence of that is that
people become less capable of making
discerning,
rational judgements,
particularly in the moral sphere.
So the consequence of those things is
that Donald Trump is right there with
the answer and I just read a piece about
the number of people who,
who support trump who won't admit it,
is far higher,
which is terrifying and we know that the
way we don't want to create adversarial
relationships.
I mean if so,
I think that part of this problem,
I don't want to go down this rabbit hole
necessarily,
but part of this problem is we have to
engage trump's arguments on his own
terms.
And part of that is if the idea is that,
that this is going to make America
safer,
I think that's what we should.
We shouldn't appeal to patriotism,
which we should take a look at that.
I don't think that claim is true.
I don't think that's borne out by the
evidence.
I don't think there's any reason to
think that first off,
it's not even constitutional.
Any of the keeping people out based on
religion or we can accept.
We can just bracket that.
Yeah,
and we can just look at,
okay,
what is the consequences of this?
and you know,
what is the concept?
Well,
let's see.
Well what is the content you think that
muslim,
islamic.
It's again,
so we need to figure that they're
getting caught in words.
Even this.
Isn't that the crazy thing?
Yeah.
They've made us also crazy about words
that whatever you were about to say
there,
you had to think about it 18 different
ways.
Even though you're sitting across from
somebody that you know is okay with the
idea of what you're going to talk about.
I was,
I was caught because I said,
okaY,
well we should have defined the term
islam is the religion,
the belief,
the ideas that so and mostly from the
people of the people and it for some
reason that seems to be an unbelievably
too way too complicated for people to
understand.
I don't understAnd,
why do you think that is?
Because it,
and it also seems like they can only do
that with islam,
like the issue only seems to be with
islam because if we were to say anything
about christianity,
people would be saying,
great job.
You're awesome all day long.
Or if you say anything about radical
islam,
they'll say,
well,
the crusades,
which is right.
So that.
So you did it.
Okay.
So that's right.
Because that's.
Remember I said the values,
they hold her egalitarianism,
relativism for them in their minds.
Egalitarianism.
Look,
every age has had a dominating value.
In aristotle he talks about the and
gentlemen in homer.
It was strengthened little tara was
humor and now it's,
it's in one side.
It's egalitarianism in relatives.
for them,
everything has to be relative.
It'S like the,
the,
uh,
usually the default is relativistic and
andy galatarian.
So while they have their band guys,
but you have your bad guys.
I'm actually no,
actually those things are not morally
equivalent.
And so,
so you're asking the question was,
was a pertinent and it's one that should
be explored.
Like what is that about?
I think part of it is that we've
extended the,
the umbrella of rights a wider and wider
and I want to be crystal clear that I'm,
I'm being descriptive,
not evaluative.
I'm describing the state.
I'm not saying it's good or bad,
you know,
I was just at a restaurant with my buddy
there before we came here and you know,
I don't eat,
um,
I try to eat only cruelty free meat so I
won't eat that's school.
So we've now extended the umbrella of
rights to,
to animals,
right?
So that is constantly extending.
So the next step for some people is to
extend that to ideas.
We've extended that and,
and I.
And I think that's really interesting,
right?
You got it.
Sorry,
go ahead.
Yeah,
no,
I want to throw it again in that for a
second.
So we've extended the ideas of rights,
which used to be for people now to
animals because we want to treat animals
better.
Minority.
The next version of that will be with
ideas.
So we're going sorta take,
we're going to put on even softer gloves
and when it comes to ideas,
because even that should be held in some
sort of.
Yeah,
because people,
as I said in my tam talk,
ideas don't deserve dignity.
People do,
and it's kind of become a meme,
but it's true.
It's,
it's that.
It's just the next kind of radical.
Taking that idea and extending it
further on,
and the problem with that is that you do
a disservice to those people holding
beliefs because you don't respect their
beliefs to engage them enough.
Let's do the thing that's really not
talked about.
This whole enterprise is really one of
disrespect that they're.
They're trying to engender these values
of respect but not listening to people,
not engaging people,
people's ideas.
Even,
you know,
you've talked about your show,
the soft bigotry of low expectations.
I think it was bush bushes phrase and I
kept crediting bill maher,
which at least sounded nice.
Now I'm quoting George W.
Bush.
I don't know.
I feel like,
well,
I don't know.
So then you'll be an con,
right?
Everybody's going to gang up on us
because they're going to say,
look at you guys.
You're really love bush deep in your
heart.
Yeah.
No,
that's actually not true.
That's just a fabrication.
That's the kind of mental gymnastics
people need to do to keep their
ideological biases in place.
Yeah.
Well that was one of the things,
you know when we launched the show in
order to sam was the first guest and he
said that they're always looking,
that these people are always looking for
something in you,
not that you've said this opinion or
that you've shared this idea,
but if they can somehow link together
something that gets them to where they
want you to be,
you're out.
Yeah,
and just thInk about this kind of
person.
Think about discharging that impulse
that you have.
Think about the kind of person that you
are.
It's difficult for me to say without,
without being overly harsh and as soon
as example of a time when someone ought
to be overly harsh,
but that makes me feel really sad for
somebody.
Yeah.
Well that's.
That's very much how I feel I had out of
all of this because like I could barely
speak what I'm saying because this,
this situation has cost me friends and
relationships already and I've only been
talking about this stuff for a couple
months and so I see the way people have
turned on me and I,
I've gotten into big debates with
friends and said,
can you point me to where I said what
you're accusing me?
And they never do because they can't.
So thAt's that.
So,
so if I may ask you,
what is the point of contention you
lost?
Was that an issue?
Was it a sweet one who exists in the
world that we exist in?
That's public person,
uh,
who I no longer talk to anymore who's
been a good friend of mine for the last
couple of years,
said that my whole show now is about
bigotry to muslims.
And I said it's actually the complete
route.
I'm trying to separate people from the
ideology and trying to show that not
everyone believes this.
I brought on people repeatedly to talk
about tolerance.
You know,
the way they'll frame,
they'll say sam and majid that they're,
uh,
that these are the bigots they're book
was called.
It was about islam and the future of
tolerance,
not islam in the future of nuclear war,
you know,
so it's,
it's these mental gymnastics as you just
said.
So what would that person lIke you to do
not talk about it?
I suppose not talk about these important
issues.
Okay.
But I'm not going to do that.
Right.
But then again,
that goes back to what we started the
conversation with them.
That's why you get trump's.
Yeah,
exactly.
SO I don't,
I would ask them.
So that's kind of the feasibility test
that I talk about in the book.
And the app haS the feasibility tests.
It's under.
What conditions do you think that that
belief would be?
False.
You can leave.
It doesn't have to be religion.
You can use the usability tests is not
my idea.
It's matt mccormick's.
You can use the usability tests with
anything.
So under what conditions could I
demonstrate to you that I am not a
biased against muslims hydro?
If they say to you,
well,
there are no conditions,
well that's a type of belief closure.
There's,
then there's,
there,
there almost is no conversation.
then you have to take a step back and I
hate to say this,
but to the metal level and have a
conversation about that.
Um,
but,
but I think that,
I don't know.
I'm now,
now I'm kind of ideating.
I think I'm concerned about your
friendship with this person.
I mean,
I've given up basically because once,
because after being called a bigot
repeatedly and saying,
actually,
no,
and can you point me to any,
and I know I'm not a big,
you know,
uh,
Douglas Murray said something really
interesting on sam's podcast.
He Said,
I have no time anymore for people whose
intentions are not good.
You know what I mean?
So I know I'm not a racist,
so if you want to call me a racist or
call me a bigot,
it actually,
since I'm not,
I don't like being called a racist or a
bigot,
but it doesn't really have any meaning
because it's just a word.
If I was secretly racist and you were
calling me a racist,
I suppose I would struggle with it a
little bit more,
but so that's,
that's the hard thing about,
that's that really is difficult about
dealing with people who are insincere
and I think a lot of those attacks on
sam,
like in philosophy,
this thing called a hermaneutic of
charity.
You want to give everybody a charitable
reputation and you want to say,
okay,
these guys actually believe this stuff,
you know,
but over time you just have to grow up.
Yeah,
I mean I,
I,
I hate to say this,
I'm,
and I don't hate to say this because
it's.
I should have woken up to this
conclusion long ago.
I don't think these people are sincere.
No,
I don't think so at all.
But that's hard to grasp too.
It is hard to grasp because if they
thought they had the truth,
why wouldn't they be sincere?
Yeah.
So excuse me.
That's,
that's the thing thAt kind of keePs me
from going on a full throttle attack.
I mean,
maybe the,
their cognitive software has somehow
been hijacked by this moral.
This idea that they think that they're
defending the downtrodden and we,
you know,
we need to do this as an examPle.
It's okay to do this because we're
stripping some,
you know,
there's some utilitarian calculus,
like,
oh,
it's going to be in the greater goods.
I don't know what goes through their
mind,
but that's the problem with dealing with
someone who's insincere.
Yeah.
So I do think that I think that they
think,
and maybe I,
I'm probably giving them the,
the leash,
that they wouldn't afford me.
Right.
But I do think they think as much as
said he thought he said they think that
they were in a war.
So they're gonna use whatever tactics
they have.
What I find particularly odd about it is
that now that we live in a digital age
where everything is recorded and you can
be quoted,
you know,
talking to this person about this or
this person about that even when they're
confronted with new evidence or frontier
or exposed as frauds,
they just doubled down even more,
which is incredible.
Yeah.
So,
so I share your frustration and I'm
sympathetic with it.
Um,
I dunno,
I,
I would,
I mean I'm a hey look,
I just,
I'd call your friend again and say,
hey look,
I've been thinking about this.
let's have a talk.
I mean,
I wouldn't let that friendship go
because that's not like trying to get
them to sit down.
We did this over text.
They wouldn't even,
they wouldn't even sit to even say let's
get coffee.
that's again,
part of the regressive left.
Yeah.
They don't want to have conversations.
They want to end those conversations.
And ironically they turn that against us
and say,
well look,
you guys are the ones who don't want to
have conversations.
And I look the whole prompt.
This is the schism and liberalism,
right?
And it was made can naked on the bill
maher show with ben affleck and sam.
And this is something again,
to solve these problems,
we need to be on it.
We need to be forthright,
we need to be honest.
We need to create environments where we
can talk about the problems and almost
if you were to,
again,
create a list of how not to solve your
problems.
These people have it.
I mean,
they've done it.
Perfect job.
You know,
what's amazing to me also is that I
never mean to go this deep into it even.
I really wanted to focus more on
atheism.
Oh,
I'm happy I'm.
We're going to go there now and I'm
happy to do this,
but what I think is particularly
fascinating about this is that
everything else that we talk about and
that we're going to talk about is so
related to this.
That's why this,
this whole situation has been so bananas
because this schism has exposed
something that I think people didn't
really realize.
But let's.
Let's just leave that portion there.
Unless you want to give me a closing
statement on that and then we'll take it
isn't.
No,
it isn't.
I just think that we.
This is not a very hopeful time right
now.
You know,
I mean we're dealing with very serious
ecological issues and we have people who
are apologists for big oil companies and
denialists and end of anthropogenic
global warming.
And again,
I actually do think those people should
be given a seat at the adult table and
anybody who has a view different from my
own,
as long as they provide evidence is
welcomed to have a conversation.
I think that there's something that's
morally damaging about what the
regresses are doing.
And I think people have had enough.
I have had way more than enough.
And,
and I think now like your,
your show has really caused this
catalyst almost this cascade of people
who also feel the same way and they're
like,
mines are gravitating and they've,
they've really robbed us of any idea of
hope that we have because we look at the
presidential campaign and I,
it's just.
Holy moly.
I mean,
I look at the republicans and I think,
wow,
like any one of those people would be an
unmitigated disaster.
Right?
and this is this.
I mean,
we.
All right,
we're just gonna keep going with this,
right?
No,
no,
we'll,
we'll just keep going because you're
hitting on it that,
that,
this thing is so it's so powerful
because I watched the republican debates
and I think I could never in good
conscience vote for all you people.
And,
but now part of,
there is a piece of me that when I see
that there,
this regressive group when they want to,
they all like bernie.
Now there's a piece of me that's like,
do I like the same guy they like,
that's crazy because I do like him,
you know what I mean?
But that's how perverse this whole thing
is.
That's why we have to make sure that we
separate the message from the messenger.
Yeah.
And that's why it's so difficult to do
that when you're constantly smeared.
If you use the wrong pronoun by accent.
Look,
I'm 49.
I've been growing up calling.
Uh,
he,
I,
it's not mal intent.
I'm not,
I don't have some deep moral malignancy
in me that I'm kinda,
you know,
it's like I made a fucking mistake.
And so we have,
again,
we have been there so morally right all
the time too,
you know what I mean?
There's so they're always policing
everyone else's words as if they have
high gna of ha ha,
that's,
that's part of the genius about this.
Anyway,
let's,
we'll do the atheism thing.
It's crazy though because I do want to
keep going with this because I feel each
week I feel like I can get away from
this a little bit and then something
else happens that brings me back into
it.
And we've talked about it in a little
more of a lofty way,
which is nice.
AlSo,
not so much the nitty gritty of it,
but in this sort of,
in sort of a bigger sense.
But uh.
All right.
So let's,
let's get to somebody,
and this is all going to relate back to
it,
but.
So I want to know about new atheists.
There's a,
there's an attack on new atheist as I
understand it.
New atheist pretty much are just
atheists who are finally speaking up
about atheism.
It may be a little more you,
you define it.
I think a little more specifically write
in the book.
There's a little more about that.
They're actually trying to shoot down
some ideas where an old atheist maybe
just removed themselves from the
discussion.
Is that fair?
Yeah,
I mean different people define it
different ways.
Austin,
dc.
Some people think there's no difference
between new and the old.
I think.
I do think there is a difference.
I think there a little more kind of a
forthright in their speech and people
interpret being forthright as being
disrespectful,
overly aggressive.
I think that's a mischaracterization.
I think that they've made this,
the additional move from the,
these,
this set of beliefs or this suite of
beliefs is irrational to these beliefs
are delusional.
And I think from my work delusion has
been a component of,
of how I think it's helpful to think
about the problem and uh,
but they don't take too kindly to that.
The believer,
the believer,
the average believer and you say you're
delusional.
they're usually not that responsive.
If you do that,
you haven't read the book because you
never,
you don't want to invoke a defensive
posture and something that you want to
enter into a conversation in which
people change their bullies from point
of view of safety,
so this is literally what you do in the
book.
I mean you lay out the exact tools on
how you should talk design by line word
for word as a template that you can use
and people have gone around.
One anthonY,
magna,
bosco has gone around videos on youtube
who implements the uses,
the scientific method.
What iS your confIdence in this belief?
Gives an intervention based upon the
book.
Now what is your internet post-test,
pretest intervention post stuff,
and it's amazing that the down moves
that people make and only five to 10
minutes.
So we know that this works.
We that this is effective.
We know that these sorts of very civil,
very engaging and that's the other
thing,
you never have to worry about anybody
saying they don't want to talk about
their faith.
Everybody loves.
that's the one thing that people will
get.
The one commonality among people of
faith.
They love to talk about it.
So speaking of talking about it,
I,
you also hit upon how people
are very selective in what they believe
and if you get them to admit,
well I don't believe that a this or that
happened,
right?
I don't believe some heart,
you know,
about chopping off hands are tied to
your head.
That's,
that's the crazy part.
But I believe in this other stuff.
But I think what you were saying is that
basically if you can get them to sort of
started meeting something not true,
that's sort of how you pull the string
right to then leading to getting them to
admit some other stuff probably.
Yeah.
And in a lot of that is you have to
create conditions.
And again,
this isn't me,
there's a long body of literature.
There's a long line of literature about
how to change the behavior of people who
don't want their behavior change.
It's from drug and alcohol counseling.
It's from,
you know,
motivational interviewing,
cult exiting.
This is out there,
but nobody is really synthesized it.
Nobody's brought these disparate
elements together.
So
I was partly thinking this when I was
reading the book,
what would you,
what would you say is the problem if
there's the average person that's a
believer that uses religion for
community,
you know,
celebrate some holidays,
whatever the religion might be,
um,
but isn't doing anything,
uh,
you know,
not,
not the people that are beheading
people,
but if you're just some average person
that doesn't necessarily take your faith
seriously,
but you get some sense of community,
whatever it is,
do you see an inherent problem in that?
Or is that just for you?
It's like,
well,
you're just sort of diluted,
but alright,
go,
go with it.
I do see a problem because I think that
people are wasting their life energy on
something that's not true.
They are harboring of belief about
reality that is almost definitely false.
And we just know this empirically
because of the number of different
religions that make different claims
about the world.
They can't all be right.
In fact,
there are contradictions.
Perfect one,
jesus was crucified.
Jesus was not crucified islam.
Christianity.
Mohammed was the last prophet.
muhammad was a prophet for mormons.
So people are harboring views about
reality that are true.
The other thing is I've heard people say
that a lot and I have to challenge.
I have to push back with you on
something.
I'm not so sure that people can hold a
private belief.
I'm not so sure that somebody can have a
belief and had not had that belief bleed
out.
Interaction.
hmm.
Not necessarily base speaking it,
but just by the way they are.
Can you give me an
yeah,
well that,
that's what it means to hold a belief.
I wouldn't say so.
Like I,
I don't like people.
I'm thinking about homosexuality,
but that's to charge so many users.
Your blazer,
like I don't like guys who.
This is a nice blazer.
We're brooks brothers.
I'm just going to make that.
I like guys who have brooks boilers but
like if I can't stand the smell
different,
they look different,
you know?
But,
but I'm not gonna.
I'm not gonna let that.
I'm not going to show that.
Like if I meet some,
I can work with someone who has a
blazer.
I can.
I think what it means that that's almost
a denial of what it means to have a
belief,
to hold a belief about something so,
so I'm also not sure that these beliefs
are as benign as people think that they
are.
And every time I bring that up,
people will bring out a study.
Well look at this like,
you know,
religiosity in this group correlated.
The smart people will say correlated.
The less intellectually adjoined people
will say,
you know,
some causal correlated,
okay,
whatever.
It's a huge difference,
but let's just go with it a look what
happened to you have religion,
you have lower incidence of heart
disease or whatever it is.
I think that the word you used before
was apt.
It's community.
Those benefits can be found from
community and you can get communities of
likeminded people without believing any
superstitious silliness.
You know,
you can get,
you can get like the same sports team.
I mean,
he has a community.
Yeah.
And,
and I think that you say,
well,
what's the harm of someone rooting for
the patriots?
I don't know anything about football.
What's the harm of someone rooting for
the patriots?
Well,
that,
that that's this analogous because
you're not claiming that it's objective
lee.
True.
Right?
And so if I think that the patriots are
ordained by god to win the superbowl or
whatever it is that they do,
you know,
again,
I don't know anything about sports.
So thought was good.
Yeah.
Linda,
thanks super bowl.
They'll take me down that road.
I travel,
then I get 50 hate mails.
People love football.
Um,
so,
so I think that the problem is that
people make objective claims and they
live their lives accordingly.
And this is all you got,
man.
Zach just said,
so wouldn't it be better for those
people to be invited to see reality for
what it is?
Wouldn't it be better to give those
people an opportunity to flourish?
Because if your beliefs,
if one belief,
it's like you can look at it as like an
architect tonic struggling like a big
building,
right?
If one of your beliefs on the bottom
level of that building,
it's contaminated like a base belief,
like jesus rose from the dead order,
then all of the beliefs that flow from
that are stemmed from that becomes
suspect.
So if you,
if you.
So what's the harm?
The harm is that if you want to enaBle
yourself to flourish and you want to
enable your community to flourish,
you have to align your beliefs with
reality because if you don't,
then what you think is objective,
moral of the right thing to do will
actually be leading you away from
flourishing.
Right?
So that's interesting.
So almost in a way you then systemically
you have to constantly be compromising
because no matter how much new evidence
comes in to prove something else,
you really have to skirt around it
because you built sort of your,
your base in things that aren't true.
Yeah,
and you put your finger on the cognitive
problem.
The cognitive problem is then in order
to reconcile that,
they make a virtue out of not revising
their beliefs.
they make a sin.
Then you need to import new words,
words that have words that are anathema
to belief,
revision like sin,
like sacred and that buttresses or
protects those beliefs from being
revised.
So there's a whole mechanism to keep
this that almost like I talked about in
the book,
it's.
It's almost if you look at it
epidemiologically how these things
spread,
like memes.
They spread the medically.
When you really think about that,
the harm is that literally billions of
people are living in ways that they
think is just and kind and right and
it's not and nation states are created
around that and we're in a very serious
problem with technology and the
instantaneous flow of an access of
information.
We are in a problem that we can no
longer afford.
Not only to ignore that,
but to disallow.
There we go the rest of leftist ago,
but to disallow conversations about
those things.
We look a shocking number of people in
this country,
and I'm ashamed to say this,
but that doesn't.
Don't Shoot the messenger.
Do not want muslim immigration.
They want to target people and not their
beliefs.
We need to have a talk about that,
ignoring that is not only not going to
make it go away,
but it's going to make that percentage
increase and that's the thing that the
regressives just cannot seem to
understand that.
So,
and of course we're back to no,
but that's okay.
So the but the point being that.
so then if you were to take someone like
sam who's having extremely difficult,
complex thought out conversations about
the difference between islam and muslims
and islam,
islam and jihad and all those things,
and if you put him in the same bank as
trump,
there is nobody left.
I think that for me exactly,
that for me is why I've taken this so
that I've taken this thing on because I
saw this guy who I told sam to his face.
I didn't even know who he was before
that,
right?
Believe it or not,
I,
I didn't reallY know.
I didn't follow them on twitter.
I had never read any of his books.
I had maybe heard of him,
but I watched that thing and I thought,
jeSus,
here's a guy trying to tell the truth on
some pretty controversial things and
look at the way he's beIng the
even trying to ask questions and that's
what's so interesting and that's what
you moral look.
It's complicated.
Moral arguments are just complicated.
That's why you have guys very smart
individuals who have substantive
disagreements about eating animals
factory from this is complicated,
but that's more reason and not less
reason to talk about it and what they've
done to sam is that they have created
conditions to make it impossible for
people to speak.
They have really done exactly the
opposite of what they.
The danger of what's going on in the
colleges really,
because you were usIng.
Sam is one example of this,
but if they can breathe that ideology in
the colleges now it goes to what you
were saying before.
You worry about the future because now
you're going to bring up all these
people with all this idea.
So it was some of this though that to
have these conversations.
First off,
people,
we view things on vine in six seconds,
140 characters and I'm really happy to
be doing long form again and I really do
believe that it's coming back and I get
emails every day saying that people are
digging it so we're on to something,
but it's part of it that to have real
discussions about real things and
especially when you take,
when you do it from the religious angle
and and atheism and all that.
Well,
you're basically bill maher and dawkins
and a couple oTher people that are
really in the limelight of it and that
you're putting too much on a few people
and that's sort of the reverse of how
this should go if you want to have real
open discussion.
Right?
Yeah.
Putting a lot on a few people.
Aaron,
for example,
sorry to,
but for example,
people always.
I'll defend bill maher in related to
this and people say,
well,
he's a dick about it and he's throwing
it in everyone's face and all that.
And although we say,
well,
I grant him a leash on this because he's
fighting the good fight,
in my view,
he's fighting thing that's so hard to do
and really using reason to explain
complex things.
So I have to,
if he's a little bit of a dick about it.
Alright.
It's guess what?
There's plenty of dicks or the other
side too.
It's interesting.
And again,
I think again,
afflecks respect clip was just perfect.
Afflecks response was so implematic.
Now I don't know if rogan's right.
I have no idea if this guy is such a
good actor.
He had us all believe in.
I really,
I can't.
I don't,
I don't know the answer to that,
but I do know is that that reaction is
more typical than ever now and we need
less of that reaction.
Here's one way that we may want to think
about getting less of that reaction.
And I'm not being facetious when I say
is an incredibly sincere.
virtually every time I speak to some and
not every time,
you know,
they're a professional apologist and
that goes out the window virtually every
time.
Excuse me,
when I'm speaking with someone,
I always think to myself maybe they know
something.
I don't know if you can just attempt to
hold that in your head in.
I have found in conversations with
religious people,
it's been very helpful.
I will admit to you,
I almost cannot do that any longer with
the regressives because because they
make a slip of the tongue into some
monstrous,
heinous act or I always feel that it's
personal.
Like it's deeply personal.
Like there's something,
there's something in me that they need
to cleanse or something like there's
some kind of like,
well that's what I mean
about the authority or anything.
Like they're in a weird way they're
doing religious trickery.
They are doing.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
The horseshoe they're buying.
they're using a lot of the tactics.
So the question is like,
what do we,
how do we engage these people?
I mean this is a very.
This is a very difficult question.
Particularly when they now have at their
disposal.
They've been there,
they've infested academia,
you know,
like what do we do in these people now
the rule makers.
Well,
it's interesting that the more I try to
bring this towards atheism,
the more it comes back to this because
it seems to me that they're there at the
attacks that they've done on the new
atheists where they use it as a
pejorative.
Now you're a new atheist.
It's sort of some sort of evil creature,
even though I don't know many.
I don't know anyone really that
identifies as a new atheist as a,
I don't think maybe sam does.
I,
I'm not even sure.
Um,
I don't know,
but they've just muddied the water.
You were just saying you don't identify
as an atheist.
So yeah,
I mean,
you can attempt to smear me.
You can attempt to.
But the irony is joe and I talked about
this.
It's like I have never heard a person
used the word intersectional who wasn't
just a nasty,
who wasn't just a really just mean
spirited,
angry person.
Yeah.
And so,
and,
and I think that is part of the.
Of course I should be indignant because
I'm a good person.
Good people become indignant at these
things.
Yeah.
So,
okay,
we're going to talk about atheism or
we're going to go back.
Okay,
this is fine.
We're Going to do what kind of chart
could we do on this?
I'm ready to back.
Yeah,
I know.
I know you're going with me.
So I think part of the problem is also
that when people have made the choice to
make the leap of faith,
right,
whatever the religion that they've
jumped in in a certain way,
even though I think in their eyes
they're doing something very lofty and
in a certain way you're doing,
you're just.
I view it as sort of like you're giving
up sort of your like this.
The world is a pretty fucked up place.
I don't know the answer so I'm just
going to leap and just hope that this.
So is that,
is that part of why it makes the
rational person's argument to them?
Very difficult because there you're,
you're arguing against something that's
not rational in its most pure form that
I.
Did I get somewhere there.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Only because I think different people
believe for different reasons and so.
So I,
I don't know.
here's what I do know,
unlike this belief that seems to be out
everywhere,
it seems to be going around,
you can actually reason people on an
audit of unreasonable positions.
In fact,
I was just talking to my.
My buddy that's a couple of days ago,
john w dot loftis.
I wrote the forward to his new book.
He was a disciple of the greatest
christian apologist senator.
He reasoned,
so jerry [inaudible],
the list goes on and on and on of people
who have done that,
and I think it doesn't start with reason
so much.
It starts with honesty.
You really think there was a talking
snake like no bullshit like you think,
but yet if you looked at your garden and
you're raking up and a snake started
talking to you,
you'd be freaking out,
right?
Yeah.
So,
so I.
Nobody would believe you and no one
would believe you.
Right?
so these things cohere in a very
complicated.
Not to use a big word,
but covariance set of beliefs that
reinforced our beliefs,
et cetera,
et cetera.
So I don't think that there's.
We can narrow it down to one note or one
data point for why people believe.
I think it's a very complex equation.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny,
I haven't thought of this so literally
until just this second,
but years ago,
I think in 1997,
so I was 21.
I went to Egypt and I was at mount
sinai,
which is supposedly where moses got the
10 commandments and I hiked up the
mountain.
It's a long hike.
You're supposed to do it at night.
I did it during the day I ran out of
water.
I mean I was basically delusional.
My stomach was messed up from apes and
bad pigeon in cairo.
I mean I was.
If I was,
if there was ever a moment where I was
gonna have a spiritual awakening,
like that's where it was because I was
compromised in my body.
Right.
And I remember not getting it all.
I mean,
I remember going to the top of that
thing and thinking like if,
if there's something here,
you got to give me a sign,
right?
Like if there's something here and this
is where moses supposedly saw the
burning bush and got the 10 commandments
and all that,
then you've got to give me something and
there was nothing.
So for me that was sort of like,
oh god is very good at hiding.
Yeah,
great height or this guy.
and I think that that's kind of.
I mean,
if you Really think about this,
I apologize ahead of time.
If this loWers your iq by a couple of
points for jews,
peep,
people will say,
well,
that's why you need faith because there
is no evidence or there is no.
There is nothing for god.
You just have to have faith in that,
but you don't act that way in any other
aspect of your life.
Like you know,
there's no other arena in that in what
you think like that.
Can I,
can I go back to your friend,
your friend again because they're still
thinking about this.
So what if you had another belief that
had nothing to do with muslims or islam
that that friend found odious,
they would probably let it slide.
I think that's where you're going.
That's what I'm going.
Yeah,
that's what I'm.
That's what I'm amazed about with this
whole thing.
This seems to be the one sticking point
they can.
So what is that?
What does that so,
so vachon opportunity.
I'll tell you what that is.
that's an opportunity for your friend to
reflect,
to sincerely reflect about the moral
priority that she or he has given this
one issue and to ask yourself,
well,
does that seem just as an outsider,
as an outsider,
does that seem that that this one issue
should trump everything else?
Because I'm frankly,
I don't even know if I'm concerned about
their wellbeing.
I'm concerned about their well
priorities.
Well that was also part when we were
having this discussion,
but you get amazon text which also felt
so weekend.
It felt like nothing.
You know,
when you're having a video conversation
with someone and you can feel a weight
to it and you can feel important to do
it over text felt ridiculous.
I mean not even email,
which also wouldn't have felt great,
but I could not get this person to sit
down with me,
um,
that there would've been nothing else.
And I,
and that's your point,
there would be nothing else.
And when I said,
well,
is there evidence of this?
Have I ever in all the time that you've
known me,
right?
Was I secretly doing this yet?
So here's the thing that I've been,
I've been saying it about the thing that
I try to be careful of what I've been
noticing.
It's like I sometimes if somebody has a
belief that's just so out in left field,
it's really easy for me and I try to
rein myself in with this internal
tendency.
I don't verbalize it articulated if
thinking that these people have mental
disorders,
like it's very,
you know.
and then I'll talk to people who believe
in actual talking snakes and stuff.
And again,
these are very nice people.
They're very easy to talk to.
I debated the guy in perth,
a,
I still keep in touch with them,
written to each other.
There is something about literally
believes that he talks to the snakes.
No,
in talking snakes,
like in the bible.
Oh,
leave that.
He did him.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
That's a whole different level of
person.
And I said,
yeah,
that,
that is,
uh,
and it's,
it's,
it's very difficult for me,
dave,
I,
I try not to characterize people whose
beliefs are so far afield of mine that
they have mental disorders and I find
it,
I think I find that the type of people
who go into religion are the sort of
people who tend to be imbalanced anyway
and they find a nice community for that,
a way to discharge those bizarre blues.
It's the same thing with the regressives
oh,
you're supposed to keep talking about.
Yeah,
they find this wonderful social justice
warrior place where they can be behind
their keyboard and angry and smear
people that get all the hate and the
reach and they.
And it's very difficult for me to rein
myself in and not write them all off as
people who have mental disorders.
And I'm,
as part of my work,
man,
I'm trying.
I hear you in the most that I can
possibly hear someone.
Yeah,
I hear you.
And that's why I find it exhausting and
it is exhausting.
I wonder,
so for you,
even before the regressive thing took
hold so much,
this discussion,
a discussion about,
you know,
free thinking and critical thinking
versus faith and things you can prove
and then you toss in some of the
regressives how exhausting is this for
you on a,
on a day to day basis because I do find
that it can be extremely exhausting that
at the end of the day I can have trouble
shutting off my mind or I'll wake up at
six and I click on twitter and then I
immediately see craziness before I've
gotten out of bed and I do find it sort
of exhausting.
What about for you?
Yeah,
I think that's because you care a lot
and I don't really care about like the
negative things people send it to.
I really don't.
I mean I legitimately don't die of
pressing things that I care about my
family and my health.
Friendships,
you know,
relationships and I don't.
But I guess in a sense I'm genuinely
interested in what people believe and
why they believe it and how it's
possible to hold preposterous beliefs.
So it's just presently perennially
interesting to me.
What's problematic though in what is
exhausting are the constant ways that I
self because I'm afraid of academic
punishment or they're constantly and I
just had another complaint filed against
me or the ways that I can't.
And it's not that I know that the
administration has said anything to me.
It's the culture in which were the
Academic culture now is you,
you just have to be extremely cautious
about what you say,
particularly in regard to islam or
particularly regardless.
There are certain things you don't have
to be conscious whatsoever.
If you want to criticize big pharma,
you can just use a thing like in class
you can say fuck shit,
you can say want but don't use a pronoun
wrong or don't say,
you know,
don't slip again.
Forty $9 with the retarded word.
I don't do that anymore.
But you know,
the things that are exhausting to me are
the mechanisms that are in place that
prohibit the free expression of ideas
and not necessarily that I don't have
tenure and I'll never get tenure.
Not necessarily that anything.
It would be a career ender,
but it is a theft of my time.
It is now.
I have to constantly go deal with it and
I have to have it in the back of my mind
and then,
oh,
if I say something else,
I have another complaint and then I'll
be the guy who gets all these
complaints.
So it's working within these and you
know,
the other thing I was thinking about
last night is that what this does in
essence is it pushes the whole system
towards mediocrity.
It pushes the whole system because then
people are afraid to voice controversial
ideas or opinions or give sides that
students wouldn't here.
They want to be the people who don't get
complaints filed against them.
So they take the evil,
the,
the ease you,
they take the easy courses you know in
and what they're not talking about is
like,
for example,
nothing to do with the regressive left,
but our end,
a cognitive disability in it's
challenged.
More philosophy were to read a great
book about that.
We're not talking about the status.
Peter singer has really interesting
stuff about this philosopher of what
should the status of cognitively
disabled people be and he says they
should be more equivalent and treatment
too.
I don't want to mischaracterize them,
but to to to basically a pigs and cows.
I think that that's an important
conversation to have and the whole
system is then being pushed towards
mediocrity because professors don't want
to deal with it.
They don't.
They just can't stomach or handle all
these ridiculous student complaints,
so they just don't teach it.
Yeah.
Why are you never going to get tenure?
All.
I was told that I could publish 10 books
from harvard and I never get tenure
here.
It was like the best thing that ever
happened in the moment after this guy,
my I won't say who is this person told
me this.
I wrote an article.
I'm like,
well,
okay,
well since I'm never going to get
tenure,
and I know that there's nothing I can do
independent of my accomplishments,
I'll never get promoted.
I it just felt was the most freeing
feeling ever.
I left his office and I wrote a little
piece of something that I published,
some like a,
what should the role of the educator be?
And I said that the role of the educator
should be to change students' beliefs if
they're not in alignment with reality,
seems to be totally uncontroversial.
My colleagues freaked out about it.
The piece went viral.
This is brief how this chronology and I
got in touch with sam harris and then
uh,
some guy from paul party from
philosophy,
so said you want to do a podcast?
And when the podcast sam harris tweeted,
we need more educators like peter
boghossian,
how I got in touch with dawkins.
Dawkins just tweeted it and that,
that just started this whole cascade.
But I've never felt more free to talk
about anything that I want,
knowing that I could be fired at any
instant.
I'd love that.
Actually.
It's a freedom that I relish.
Well,
I love it.
I love it because it shows you the
importance of ideas,
which is really,
that's the big thing here,
that everything else is couched in,
right?
That you had an idea,
you shared it.
And then your idea was shared by people
that you respect and admire,
who you credit in your book for helping
you get to this place,
and then they spread an idea and that,
I guess to sort of bring this all around
is what the regressives are fearing.
And That's why they want to silence
everyone because they don't like.
They don't like your ideas.
Right?
So that they're not going to debate
them.
Yeah.
They don't like it.
They think they have the truth.
It is really a bizarre kind of a pistol.
Logical myopia.
Not even,
it's just that they,
they have these ideas that they're
completely convinced are true.
Again,
like religion,
holding them makes them better people.
They're sacrosanct.
You can't criticism.
Not only can you,
you can't even ask about him.
Can you ask how they derived it?
Bang.
Interlaced in there.
So morally sure of sanctimonious.
I guess that's why I wanted to bring
this around to relate it to religion
because I had been trying to put this
all together and there is these
underpinnings that are so the same of
the authoritarian religious thing.
It's all there.
It really is all there.
It's like they hate really there on the
left.
So they hate religion,
christianity,
right?
Then they have one religion that they
want to protect,
uh,
because it's,
it's,
uh,
the downtrodden religions and then it
just,
everything they do is in,
it's a constant shell game.
They're just moving the goal posts all
the time and how intellectually
exhausting must that be for them.
And I don't think it's that tiring for
them because they're just so ingenuine
and since that's what I've come to
believe because many people every day I
get email people saying,
why don't you sit down with one of these
guys and there's,
you know,
there's a list of the public ones that I
could sit down with,
right?
And I know some of them personally and
it's like,
what,
what could we do if I had been exposed
repeatedly as liars as they have and as
repeatedly with bad intention.
So then for you,
for you someone that deals in the moral
landscape Without religion,
right?
And deals and critical thinking,
what,
what should the decision process be?
For me?
You know,
because I think about all the times.
Yeah,
I guess I could do it.
I.
Okay,
so
here,
here's a piece of mine.
My friend jerry coyne said this to me,
very evolutionary biologist,
very useful piece of information when
somebody's trying to say this without
pumping this,
giving this person in the identity.
But here's what I think you should do it
give you the piece of advice he gave me.
Yeah,
people are going to criticize you no
matter what.
So if someone says to you,
hey,
you know I'm going to donate to charity,
I'm going to do this.
The question I think is,
do you think that this person is sincere
and honest in their engagement with you?
Not what would I get out of it?
Not what would they get out of it,
not even what would it do to further the
discourse,
but is this a sincere person who,
who's willing to sit down and talk with
me and look at the evidence and are
their beliefs to feasible?
Are they willing to,
you know,
hey,
look,
dave,
I came in here.
I thought this had a conversation with
you,
but equally important,
you have to ask that of yourself.
Right,
and if,
if that is absent from that discourse,
it's just a farce.
So why would you,
you should.
That should never listen to someone on
twitter.
You going to have this global fuck you
like have your own show.
You know,
you should never listen to you.
You're not held hostage to the
irrationality of others.
Yeah,
I like that.
That's a good ending.
That sounds like a good ending.
We could have done so much more here and
I pretty much,
I could have just mixed these up.
I don't even know that I really looked
at them,
but I could have just thrown them all
over.
I'm dying to know it's on there.
You can have those.
we will absolutely do this again and
then we'll.
And I won't bring any of those cards and
we'll just see,
see what happens.
But the beauty of this is that this,
this is big and this is what a lot of
people have wanted to talk about and I
liked the fact that I'm able to talk
about it with people that are dealing
with it in different ways.
So at the academic level and the and the
religious level or belief level and then
people are dealing at the political
level and all that.
And you've been a catalyst.
I mean you've brought people together,
you've talked about an issue that's
important.
More and more people are becoming aware
of that and you've kind of,
you've,
you've become a figure in which people
go to and they look to and they respect
for these sorts of conversations to help
them navigate these difficult terrain
because these are not easy issues.
Particularly not easy.
When again,
a lot of the arguments that people on
the progressive regressive have,
they really should be taken earnestly.
You know,
treating people,
not treating people differently in the
basis of skin color.
I mean these are really important things
and we need to be sensitive to how we
behave.
We need to be more kind and more just
and more compassionate.
The way to do that is not through the
regressives.
the way to do that is by being honest
and sincere with ourselves and having
these sorts of discourses,
having these kinds of dialogues.
I want to thank peter because he in for
joining me.
You can check out his work at peter
boghossian dotcom and buy a manual for
creating atheists wherever books are
sold.
Thanks for watching and we will do it
again next week.